-Guys, here's how this works.
We're going to have a number
of mystery objects
brought out in front of us,
and our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have
to figure out by touch alone.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I -- really,
I said it's a fun game,
but I really don't mean that.
-Have there ever been actual
dangerous things in there?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Okay.
-There's been one
or two dangerous things.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Usually towards the end,
though, right?
-Oh, great. Whatever.
I'm down. I like to touch.
-Since I'm the host,
I'm going to go first.
-Okay.
-All right.
Let's get our first object.
All right.
And you can go in front,
if you want.
And just --
-Okay.
-I'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Is it --
-So there are scary ones,
apparently.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm going to freak out.
I'm freaking out.
I swear to you, this is
not my game at all, man.
I'm like -- [ Screaming ]
Don't make noise. Is it
going to move or something?
I swear --
-Come in through the side.
-This is the last time
I'm playing this game ever.
I just really don't
like this at all.
Oh!
-You're fine!
-Oh!
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
-Butter?
Is it sticks of butter?
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Get this out.
-It seems so easy.
-Yeah? It seems so easy,
well, get ready,
you're about to play this game.
Oh, man.
Get ready.
Oh, you are good at that.
All right, here we go.
[ Audience groans ]
-The reaction is the worst part.
[ Laughter ]
I make fun of it.
I've been watching this game.
-Ugh!
Ew!
-Stop it.
[ Laughter ]
-Ow!
-What was that?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I'm going this side.
-Okay, no!
[ Screaming ]
-[ Screaming ] What is it?
Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
-Trust me, I won't --
seriously, I'm being serious.
-Oh.
-Do whatever you touch
with that hand.
Yeah, that's it.
Yep. Go right in.
-No.
-I promise you. Trust me.
That hand. That hand.
-I'm sweating now.
-Trust me. It's that hand.
You've got it. You've got it.
That's it.
Feel what that is.
You can squish it
between your fingers.
-No!
Oh, God, is it an ant farm?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-It's not an ant farm.
It was -- It's a sand castle.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's close.
I mean, ant farm was close.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Maybe we'll give you credit.
I know, it's tough right?
-Wow.
-It's a mental game, right?
-Holy cow.
-All right, oh, no.
This one looks big.
Why is this box bigger
than the other box?
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ominous music plays ]
-You've got to go down.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, once you --
once you feel the top,
you'll want to go down.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I don't even know what it is.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
You've got this.
You got it!
No! [ Screaming ]
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Is it -- did it lick me?
There's wetness. There's wetness
on my finger right now.
Something liquidy is in there.
-Yeah.
-Oh, it's liquid. It's warm.
It's going to be an amphibian.
It's going to be a frog.
A frog.
-I'm looking at it,
and I have no idea what it is.
[ Buzzer ]
-Should I just try to touch it
one more time?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It appears to be docile.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Screaming ]
Ew! Ew! Gross!
Disgusting! Ew!
Was it an eel or a snake
or something?
An eel? What is that?
-I don't know what it is.
[ Buzzer ]
-What is that? Ew!
[ Laughter ]
Are you joking me?
That is not in the rules at all
or any respect for me at all.
What in the hell is that?
-I have no idea.
-What is that?
-It's a lung fish.
-Lung fish?
What is a lung fish?
-I don't know.
-Oh, my God.
Is it like a catfish?
-He's a sleepy lung fish.
[ Audience awws ]
I want to touch him.
Aw, guys.
I want to cook it.
-All right -- Oh, my God.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No cooking any of our animals.
-That's where my mind goes.
-All right, you are up now.
Here you go. Good luck.
It's fun.
It's going to be fine.
[ Audience groans ]
You want a hint?
-I mean, yes.
-Have you seen "Jurassic Park"?
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Is it Bryce Dallas Howard?
-I wish.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys.
[ Ominous music plays ]
-Dude, just --
This is legendary, dude.
That's all I'm saying.
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What happened? What happened?
What happened?
-It bit me.
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, it bit you.
We can give this one away.
It is a toy.
It's a toy dinosaur.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Applause ]
It didn't really bite you.
Send whoever's in here away.
-I'm sorry.
-Was that frightening?
-I thought it could have
been John for a second.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I know.
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh.
This is real.
-This is real, right?
-People don't get it.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Wait! Wait!
-I'm out.
-We're supposed to do
this together.
-No, man.
No! No.
-This is --
-No.
This is my --
-What are you talking about?
This last one we're supposed
to one-hand in together.
-No!
-Well, now you've seen it!
-I saw it. I'm 1,000% not.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
This is might be the worst one
I've ever seen on here!
-Stop it right now.
-That's all I want to say.
[ Laughs ]
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Too mad, so sad, everything --
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
You guys...
[ Audience cheering ]
-I have no idea what it is
at all.
But I did touch it right?
[ Buzzer ]
-That was good though.
-I'll guess. Is it a snake
or something like that?
Or -- is it a lizard?
-No.
-Oh, is it a frog?
Ew!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Are you out of your mind?!
What in the -- what?
Is that cockroaches?!
-Yeah.
-Are you out of your mind?!
-Like I --
-Oh, my gosh!
-I'll touch anything, but...
♪♪
-My thanks to Chrissy Teigen.
[ Cheers and applause ]